we see the oculus rift
in virtual reality because you can look
around you can look behind you you can
look below you above you we have to end
up building the entire world we can't
really kind of pull any tricks because
yeah as you can see I can see you but I
know your whole world over here some
people have talked about this being
antisocial don't know what you're
talking about but yeah it is a little
bit of a intimate kind of you know when
you put it on your definitely kind of
closing yourself off in the world a
little bit but i think you know like
with anything people will get used to it
and they'll start to figure out how they
want to integrate them their life and
the actual device itself is going to
continue to evolve it'll get lighter
it'll get easier to wear so you know i
don't think any of us could have
imagined ten years ago that we'd all be
carrying around these little star trek
devices in our pockets but here we are
all your well known for talking to
create words and friends how did you go
from words with friends to virtual
reality i saw a virtual reality for the
first time with the haka Swift and I
thought this is this is the future i
have to make a's for this so your
six-year-old has played this game yes
yes and what was it what did she say she
calls it the game where you go places
what's it like when you come out of this
world I just say welcome back it's not
as exciting